c'est une décision qui aura de profondes
conséquences pour la sécurité du peuple
afghan
l'otan doit se prononcer prochainement
sur le maintien ou non de ces dix mille
soldats présents en afghanistan la
plupart sont affectés à la mission de
formation des forces de sécurité
afghanes une discussion entre les 30
pays membres aura lieu ce jeudi à ce
sujet même si aucune annonce n'est
prévue à l'issue de cette réunion le
secrétaire général de l'alliance a
toutefois précisé que l'organisation
militaire ne se retirera que lorsque les
conditions seront réunies
notre objectif commun est clair
l'afghanistan ne doit plus jamais servir
de refuge aux terroristes qui s'attaque
à nos pays
notre présence repose donc sur certaines
conditions et space
bien qu'aucun des alliés ne soit traité
en afghanistan plus longtemps que
nécessaire
nous ne partirons qu'une fois le moment
venu
jens stoltenberg a directement accusé
les talibans de ne pas respecter leurs
engagements et de poursuivre leurs
attaques contre les forces afghanes et
alliées une réponse à la mise en garde
est insurgé émis ce week-end ces
derniers menacent l'otan de poursuivre
la guerre si l'organisation ne quitte
pas l'afghanistan
notre message en vue de la réunion des
ministres de l'otan et que prolonger
l'occupation et la guerre n'est ni dans
votre intérêt ni dans celui de vos
peuples ou d'une autre quiconque cherche
à prolonger la guerre et l'occupation
sera tenu responsable
comme au cours des deux dernières
décennies ces nouvelles menaces
surviennent malgré un accord conclu avec
les talibans par l'ancien président
américain en février 2001 washington et
les insurgés se sont rencontrés à doigts
pour évoquer le retrait total des forces
américaines en mai prochain
de leurs côtés les talibans se sont
engagés à ne pas laisser des groupes
terroristes agir depuis les zones qu'il
contrôle et à ne plus attaquer les
troupes américaines qui comptent encore
2500 hommes mais cette donne pourrait
changer avec l'administration de joe
biden cette dernière souhaite notamment
évaluer le respect par les insurgés de
leur engagement sur le terrain les
observateurs constatent toujours des
attaques nombreuses contre les forces
afghanes
côté politique les négociations de paix
ouverte entre les talibans et le
gouvernement afghan n'ont pour l'instant
donné aucun résultat concret